what's going on there citizens of the reject
nation greg here today to watch the trailer for
a movie that i thought this trailer was coming
out at like six in the morning but it came out
in the evening in l.a halloween ends still
positive with the vid diesel unfortunately tested
positive a few days after johnny boy did but
hopefully we're both clear by the time comic con
rolls around because i'm sure there's going to be
a lot of goodies but right now we got to rock this
trailer i really enjoyed the third first halloween
movie really enjoyed halloween kills as well so
i'm very excited for this wanted to mention a
couple things shout out reaction to the movie
sinister first time watching so i'm gonna try
to get that up tomorrow or thursday and in case
you missed our major announcement uh we recently
partnered up with heavy spoilers and screen crush
or a one-stop nerd shop for all of our merch got
a whole bunch of great gear to represent yourself
as a citizen of the reject nation but also got a
bunch of stranger things inspired here as well the
main show i want to tell you about is a limited
run inspired by one from stranger things and one
from squid game and we put one and one together
you can go to shop0edition.com and explore around
you know see if there's anything that you like
anything you guys get is a great way to support
the channel meantime leave a like that'd be
awesome and let's see the trailer for the
final final final showdown with the
it won't be though there's always more
what we got
chillin
let's go ouch
flashbacks
come and get me [__] yeah
come on
i fear that it's such like a primal fear
if anyone whoever deals a garbage disposal
i think that's a reference to one of
the halloween movies isn't it is that
h2o let me know if i'm right about that every
time i actually use a garbage disposal i think
his final destination was the first movie i ever
saw that really tempted with that and other movies
have done it too but whenever i put my hand in a
garbage disposal i'm like oh my god please don't
turn on i'm really enjoying the showdown moment
that they're teasing us with i'm assuming it's
from the finale of the film or it could be
like one of two or three fights between them
you know like it's taking place a few years after
halloween kills i could imagine a scenario where
you know someone feels inspired to become michael
myers or dress up like him and then i'm going
to attack lori and have some true crime serial
killer wish fulfillment going on but i mean this
looks like this is the real michael myers in this
scene but the first installment from this trilogy
while i like loved that finale i really did it was
a lot of machinations and contraptions a lot of
strategy this is just bringing us to a brutal raw
visceral fight bare knuckle house brawling nunia
which feels like apt for this climactic showdown
the boogeyman the ferocious unstoppable force
and the resilience of lori strode going toe-to-toe
and like this physically brute match and even the
ending shot of lori stabbing michael's hand
reflecting the iconic imagery of michael meyer
stabbing kind of weaves in thematically what
this trilogy has been doing of lori's traumatic
obsession in some ways evolving her into what
she obsesses about i'm not saying she's going to
become a serial killer or anything like that but
but i don't think you know what i'm getting at you
you've seen the other two movies but i have faith
in this movie i like the halloween 2018 2018 if
i'm correct i like that one more than uh halloween
kills and they have had two movies planned and
originally it was gonna be shot back to back but
they actually wanted to wait and see how kills was
received first so they can acclimate and readjust
especially because while there was like still
a lot of halloweenisms in that film they did
try doing different things in terms of audience
reception some of it didn't land so well some of
it did evil dies tonight so i do wonder how much
social commentary they're gonna try to push in
here because halloween kills definitely try doing
more social commentary than i think the first
halloween movie i think i think that halloween
movie definitely was doing it but it was a little
bit more overt in halloween kills at least in my
perception but i think this particular trilogy
works best when the themes really shine through
the characters emotional experiences and what
they're going through so when you keep it like
just character focused specifically on lori
strode obviously who was a miss presence for a
lot of halloween kills but i feel like especially
with the death of judy greer that's really setting
the stage for what this film is gonna offer like
i think this is a great first trailer it doesn't
give you a lot which is ideally the way you want
it to go when it comes to your horror suspenseful
movie it feels like halloween opening on
halloween with its pov voyeuristic stalking shot
misleads you into thinking like oh is someone tied
up there or is michael just about to kill another
person then you're walking in again to lori's trap
which is again establishing like this is what this
trilogy does i did read up that this movie's gonna
be taking place i believe four years after the
last movie and that it would incorporate elements
of the pandemic into the story i don't really
quite know how much again social commentary but
what i'm most interested in seeing and i hope they
really do justice to this is that we're supposed
to be seeing how the town of haddonfield who was
already just vastly disturbed and and traumatized
for decades after a few killings in 1978 i can
only imagine how much worse it is for them
after the events from four years before so
i'm interested to see how they're gonna handle the
coping of the community and how that's all gonna
unfold yeah i know i wanna see a bunch of cool
kills and thrills too but i wanna see some cool
thematic [__] happen as well what is the actual
plot synopsis of this movie hold on let me find
it four years after the events of halloween kills
lori is living with her granddaughter allison and
is finishing writing her memoir michael myers
hasn't been seen since lori after allowing the
spectre michael to determine and drive her reality
for decades has decided to liberate herself from
fear and rage and embrace life but that shape
just kicks goddamn door but when a young man
corey cunningham is accused of killing a boy oh
i actually didn't read this man is accused of
killing a boy he was babysitting and ignites a
cascade of violence and terror that will force
laurie to finally confront the evil she can't
control once and for all evil dies tonight well
that's interesting so i do wonder if the angle
of this corey cunningham character is someone who
actually did kill this child or is being framed by
michael myers who's like i'm referring to this guy
i'm not sure but i think there is some
interest like i was talking about earlier
uh in this discussion that perhaps there might
be some type of influence some psychotic sick
influence left behind and then this kid is
inspired by it or some [__] and then michael
comes back and michael's like i'm gonna adopt you
corey you're mine so yeah with halloween kills
wanting to even more social commentary and i know
they want to carry that through here so from the
sounds of things with michael haven't been gone
for several years that again they'll be continuing
that theme of dealing with trauma the struggles
of letting go and challenges to move forward
oh man this franchise is the soviet laureate she's
such a sarah connor character in the 2018 film and
in this film they're setting her up i'm like i
decided to let go and i'm going to enjoy my life
and be here be at one and then bam freaking just
when i think come out they pull me back in and
yeah you know with the way holloman kills ended
with the the death of uh judy cruz oh my god i'm
looking around judy gru's kid karen do you wonder
if we're gonna kind of get some type of cathartic
vengeance tail woven here you know where like lori
and allison are coming together they gotta avenge
the bomb but either way uh i thought this was a
great first trailer i'm excited for this movie
what did you guys think leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that bell you can
check us out at shopzeroaddition.com support
the channel and yeah we will catch you all soon